If 3 times a number is equal to 3 halves
what is the number? so let's just say
that our number..unknown number
let's just call that "x". So we could say
3 times our number x is equal to 3 halves
so now we just have to solve for x
so if we want to isolate an x here on the
left hand side, the most obvious thing
to do is 3 times x, if we divide by 3,
we're gonna left with just x
We can't just do that to one side
of the equation if we want to
maintain this equality
we have to do it to both sides
so you divide both
sides by 3 and we're going to be left with
x is equal to 3 halves divided by 3
that is the same thing as 3 halves times
one-third which is going to be
equal to one half. You can verify that
3 times one-half is 3 halves